match each function with its graph and
we have graph D a B and C and let's just
start with the graph of B because
actually this little looks the closest
to the square root of x which would look
something like that but it's clearly
shifted and it's flipped over the
horizontal axis
the fact that it's flipped over the
square horizontal axis that means that
we're taking the negative square root
we're taking the negative square root so
it's going to be one of these two cases
right over here we're shifting it down
by two so we should have a negative two
and both of these cases have a negative
two here and we're shifting it relative
to the square root of x we're shifting
it to the right by one so if we're
shifting to the right by one what we see
under the radical should be X minus one
and both of these have an X minus one on
it so which of these is B and which of
these is C and I encourage you to think
about that pause the video if you if you
like well the difference between these
two is this one has a scaling factor of
2 here while this one doesn't so this
one and it's and of course this is going
to turn into more and more negative
values this is going to be getting
negative faster and you see that graph C
here gets negative faster and you can
even try some points in either case when
X is equal to an x is equal to 1 in
either case what we have under the
radical becomes 0 X minus 1 is 0 X minus
1 is 0 when X is equal to 1 and in
either case our Y value is negative 2
but then you see as x increases as x
increases this one right over here gets
negative twice as fast and you see that
right over here this one this one right
over here relative to our starting this
this has gone down relative Y has gone
from negative 2 to negative 4 here while
for the for graph see Y has gone from
negative 2 to negative 6 so it's gone
down by 4 this has only gone down by 2
so it's pretty clear that graph B
corresponds to the one that doesn't have
the 2 out front so this is graph B right
over here and graph C corresponds to the
one that has the negative 2 out front so
let me throw that the negative 2 out
front so now we just have to think about
these two graphs or these two equations
and match them to these two graphs
and so both of these they they haven't
been flipped around the horizontal axis
they've been flipped around the vertical
axis and that's why whatever we have
under the radical we've essentially
taken the negative of it and actually we
could figure out which which ones these
are just by looking at how much they've
been shifted in the y-direction relative
to the square root of x which would be
which would look something which would
look something like something like that
I know you can't draw I can't drawn this
one right over here well this one has
been shifted up by two D has been
shifted up by two this one over here G
of X has been shifted up by two and you
could also see that it's been shifted to
the left by one if you're shifting to
the left by one normally under the
radical you would have X plus one but
then we flipped it over on to on around
the vertical axis and so that takes the
negative of that so that's why it's
negative X minus one you could view this
as the negative of X plus one so either
way that is d that is d throw that under
two D and this deductive reasoning this
tells us say that this is a and it makes
sense we see it is shifted up by one so
it's plus one and we could view this as
as the negative as the negative of X
minus four as the negative let me as the
negative of X maybe the negative of X
plus four so it's been shifted four to
the left and we see that is definitely
the case relative to the square root of
x we got it right